We're going to start today talking about John.
And there is so much to say and so many different
angles to this story.
So let's get right into it.
One of Donald Trump's former national security
advisers, because he's had many, is very close
to releasing a book.
The book is scheduled to be released on Tuesday,
June twenty third.
We have a bunch of the claims that are in
the book to tell you about momentarily.
But the first part of this is about Donald
Trump and the Justice Department under Donald
Trump's A.G., William Barr working really
hard to suppress the release of the book The
Eye.
The story needs a disclaimer.
Now, I want to be.
I'm going to keep saying this today because
it's important, because it's been a few months
since we last talked about John Bolton's book.
John Bolton is absolutely horrible.
John Bolton is of the worst of the worst when
it comes to his political worldview.
He's one of the key architects of the 2003
Iraq war, which doesn't seem he regrets being
a part of.
To this day, he's a horrible neoconservative.
He's not someone that progressives would ever
consider an ally on policy and someone whose
entire moral compass is fundamentally broken.
So I the reason I want to do this is there
is already some supposed leftists out there
talking about liberals are falling for Bush.
They're falling all over themselves to praise
Bolton.
Bad people sometimes tell the truth, in other
words, that people are always lying.
John Bolton seems to be a fierce advocate
for what he believes is right and true, and
he doesn't tend to get pushed around.
I almost always disagree with him about what
is right in this particular case.
Bolton has decided that it is correct and
profitable and this is important.
We're going to get into that to tell the story,
as he sees it, of what happened when he was
Donald Trump's national security adviser.
This is not praise of John Bolton.
And I'm going to go back to that.
So the Trump administration has been panicking
and they have sued Bolton to try to prevent
the release of the book.
Trump's Justice Department is trying to suppress
the book.
Remember this?
They said this would be the most transparent
administration ever.
The most for free speech administration ever.
They're going through any number of different
arguments, trying anything they can to see
what sticks, including claiming that the publication
of Bolton's book risks compromising national
security.
Now, there is something funny in that there
is some truth in the national security concerns
around Bolton's book.
But what I mean by that is what Bolton alleges
in the book, which I will get to, is so damning
to Donald Trump that it exposes the United
States to being taken advantage, advantage
of by showing how incompetent and clueless
Donald Trump is.
It actually might encourage our adversaries
to try to take advantage of the United States
knowing how incompetent Donald Trump is, according
to the book.
But from a legal perspective, these arguments
are all very tired.
They're likely not going to work.
Partially thanks to the First Amendment, to
the Constitution of the United States.
Now, in the lawsuit against Bolton, there's
a few different arguments.
The lawsuit says Bolton violated the contract
he signed when he became national security
adviser by writing the book.
They make another argument in the lawsuit
that says Bolton has not allowed enough time
for the book to be vetted to see if it contains
government secrets.
Donald Trump the other day said he thinks
if the book gets published, Bolton will have
criminal problems.
But before we get into that, here is Trump
saying any conversation with him is de facto
classified, which is another argument he's
making about why Bolton's book shouldn't be
published.
And somebody said he went out and wrote a
book.
He wrote a book.
I can't imagine that he can because that's
highly classified information, even conversations
with me.
They're highly classified.
I told that to the attorney general before.
I will consider every conversation with me
as president.
Highly classified.
Now, that isn't true.
Presidents can choose to classify or declassify
whatever they want.
But there is no legal basis to say retroactively.
Every conversation that I had with Bolton
is classified.
That's an insanely broad legal claim.
Courts are very unlikely to accept such a
claim.
Let's keep going, though.
Here's more of what Trump said about Bolton
being a criminal.
So that would mean that if he wrote a book
and if the book gets out, he's broken the
law.
And I would think that he would have criminal
problems.
I hope so.
Otherwise, I mean, they put a seller in jail
because he sent a photograph of his bed and
an engine of an old submarine.
And this guy's writing writing things about
conversations or about anything.
And maybe he's not telling the truth.
He's been known not to tell the truth a lot.
So legal experts believe that Bolton would
not have legal problems, but his publisher
would also potentially be liable there.
And the publisher has obviously done a huge
legal review before the book is going to print.
The First Amendment is quite strong here as
well.
Now, there is a footnote in the lawsuit against
Bolton where the Department of Justice is
asking a court to ban every bookstore in the
United States from selling the book.
That is critical of President Trump.
What would we be saying if in any other country
we saw a court being asked by a president
to ban bookstores from selling a book that's
critical of the president?
Just think about that.
And when we see all of these supposedly enlightened
hot takes from some on the left saying, oh,
it's liberals falling for it again now believing
Bolton, who in 2003 was the bad guy.
What would we be saying if a different country
was trying to use the courts to prevent bookstores
from publishing a book?
Now, the reality in terms of the vetting is
that the manuscript was first sent to the
White House's National Security Council in
December.
That's six, seven months ago.
At this point.
And ultimately, this is not about classified
information.
This is not about state secrets.
This is not really about national security.
This is about a book whose claims and content
is very embarrassing to Donald Trump.
That's really what this is about.
Now, I have to tell you, Trump's concern may
be overblown to a degree, because, yes, now
that we found out what's in the book, which
I'll tell you in a moment, a lot of media
coverage of it.
But most Trump lists aren't going to buy and
read a book with several hundred pages that
that that's not what Trump has to do.
Most Trump lists are going to see what Fox
News and Bright Bart and OJ N and, you know,
Mark Levin say about the book.
And that will be what they believe.
So I think some of the concern may be overblown,
but what we've learned so far is that Donald
Trump is focused solely on reelection.
And to the extent that he believes the book
may hurt his reelection, he's going to do
everything he can to suppress the book.
Now, we're going to talk more about skepticism
in a moment.
We should apply skepticism here to John Bolton,
as we always should.
When there is a book, because John Bolton
is going to make money from this book.
If John Bolton's only priority was to get
the truth out, he could have been doing interviews
seven months ago and telling us what's in
the book.
I'm going to argue later on in the show that
John Bolton is actually a traitor to the United
States for waiting seven months to tell us
about such damning allegations against Donald
Trump.
So there is no doubt that there is a financial
calculation here for John Bolton that doesn't
tell us whether the claims in the book are
true or false.
And we have to see if the claims pass the
sniff test.
And they do.
We have to see if the claims are similar to
those that have been made by others who have
spent time around around Donald Trump.
And they are.
So is John Bolton hypocritical in the sense
that he didn't testify for the House impeachment
trial and now he's publishing a book to make
money with absolutely bombshell claims when
he could have told us about these seven months
ago?
Absolutely.
And I'm going to slam him for it in about
15 minutes.
But that doesn't mean that the claims are
untrue and that is what we are going to be
talking about.
Again, I don't know that this is really going
to change Trump's standing with Trump ists
who aren't really going to read the book.
They don't really read, but every little bit.
Anything that can help us remove Donald Trump
in November is something that we should be
looking at very, very, very seriously.
And that's exactly what we're going to do
next